all right take this round  bring it down Oh  we feeis has landed good morning I am  Meredith Vickers and it's my job to make  sure you do yours  okay then on with the show these are  images of archaeological digs all over  the area ancient civilizations that  shared no contact and yet same pictogram  every last one it's a star map  no not am i an invitation from home  that's amaura and you do find these  beams down there  you won't engage them you won't talk to  them I'll do nothing but report back to  me miss Vickers is there an agenda that  you're not telling us about how far  would you go to keep your answers  mark out this  please use all your saying this all  right you want him to be wrong  leaf here's the ground crew limousines  picked up a lot of pork she's got a kid  but what are you paying if you're going  down there you're going to die changing  changing into what ship they leave me to  go away this it was so wrong  take us home  we don't stop it to go back to  you